he was brought to al-shifa
gaza central hospital in the middle of
the afternoon
neighbors said he'd been hit by an
israeli rocket
the doctors said he was unlikely to
survive
one more casualty in a long-running
conflict that no one's able to solve
his name
ibrahim abu salah
we ran into his funeral procession the
next morning
had died overnight
the mourners praised god as they flew
the flags of rival political factions
and they expressed their rage in a
territory that's been blockaded by the
israelis for 15 years
gaza is an open-air prison they say and
it suffered the loss of another inmate
you know what deaths like this do they
they unify people in gaza it doesn't
matter what political faction they're
from from hamas or fatah
they're all palestinians now
49 were killed in three days of fighting
between israel and militant group
islamic jihad
but abu sala's family say he wasn't
interested in the conflict
we meet them on the day of his funeral
his wife lobna looked bewildered
she told us her husband had just gone to
get some air
shrapnel litters the area where they say
the two men sat
it's a small spot shaded by a series of
lebec trees and you can see those trees
in an aerial video released by the
israeli military
officials said militants were using this
location to set up rocket launchers
leaves four children with little support
that's the story of gaza said mourners
from gaza's ruling hamas government
no no there is no any warning from
israeli he says israel attacked without
warning
but that wasn't the case here
this house belongs to the halifa family
and its destruction was carefully
planned
oh this is this is the owner here yeah
okay
let's set
says the israelis rang her neighbor in
advance to warn her about the airstrike
a little bit
then the israelis rang up again saying
they were still too close to their house
the family raced further away why do you
think they hit your buildings
as well
in gaza life and death are treated with
a weary familiarity part of a cycle that
few if any can escape
the mourners of ibrahim abu salam told
us that paradise awaits him
[Music]
but in this beleaguered spot they know
the violence will return
john sparks sky news in gaza city